à j-1 jean-pierre colombie porte parole
de l'association à policière upn y
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
pour réagir donc à cette soirée de
tension une manifestation non autorisée
mais qui était calme réunissant des
milliers de personnes et cette tension
donc ces dernières heures
quelle est votre réaction ce soir
bonsoir
voir tout d'abord un rassemblement de
20000 personnes non autorisées mais dont
la présence vous ne pouvait être qu elle
était prévisible pouvait dans ce
contexte là être envisagé comme un
problème problématique
ce qu'on voit malheureusement n'est pas
n'est pas si étonnant que ça
malheureusement il ya il ya des mois que
la tension est forte entre le quartier
et les forces de les forces de l'anp
pour des raisons complexes et variées
qui nécessiterait un temps plus long
pour l'évoquer pour l'analyser
maintenant ce que ça évoque ces petits
cons on est dans un contexte d'une
situation qui je l'espère restera
contrôlable d'un point de vue comme de
l'autre on a vécu des manifestations qui
ont dégénéré de manière ultra violente
dans les mois qui ont qui sont passées
que se sont écoulés il faudrait éviter
que à la crise sociale très forte ne
s'agrègent une un climat cette fois
populaires issus des cités encore plus
fort et qui s'agrège à tous à ce
mouvement social qui risque de faire un
dirait une synthèse syncrétisme de
tensions multiples et variées la
situation est très inquiétante
on est peut-être j'espère que ce n'est
qu'un qu'un feu de paille dans fa ce à
quoi on assiste est quand même très
violent et est pour toi d'inquiétude
c'est évident il ya une conjonction
effectivement d'événements on va
évidemment parler
voilà deux du mimétisme un petit peu ces
images qui nous viennent des états unis
l'effet d'un confinement dit vetcho pour
les français notamment dans les
quartiers compliqué et cette expertise
dont on parle depuis tout à l'heure qui
incriminent les gendarmes contrairement
aux deux
précédente expertise pour vous c'est
voilà la goutte qui a fait déborder long
du vase
ce soir vous avez un petit peu compliqué
de répondre il faudrait connaître le
dossier dans en détail si le magistrat a
estimé qu'il n'y avait aucune raison de
mettre en examen du gendarme mis en
cause par la famille c'est qu'ils
avaient des motifs à le faire après il
faut pas préjuger des suites qui seront
données au dossier vous savez témoin
assisté le statut de témoin cité peut
déboucher un moment donné sur une mise
en examen
donc il peut et on peut très bien
imaginer que dans les mois à venir ça
puisse malgré tout débouché sur sur des
audiences sur une audience pénale donc
avoir une réponse pour les familles qui
semble-t-il est le but recherché
au travers de cette manifestation dans
fin de ce rassemblement qui a dégénéré
en manifestations violentes
donc je pense qu'il faut être très
vigilant très vigilant au climat qui
règne et cette vigilance doit être le
fait pas simplement des dépôts petit des
magistrats mais également des politiques
si on fait si on ne prend pas la peine
d'analyser ce qui se passe dans ce pays
on va dans le mur c'est évident et il
faudra pas encore une fois que tout ça
se réduisent à une confrontation police
qui présideront la réputée temps tant et
tant de fois au travers de l'association
ipmi que la situation était et
socialement et au niveau de la
délinquance complexe qu'il faudrait
quand même un moment donné que devon
question soit posée et qu'on y apporte
aussi possible les bonnes réponses
aujourd'hui quand on entend voilà
certains observateurs un certain parti
politique nous dire il ya une impunité
envers les policiers quand ils
commettent des bavures on les punit pas
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
obligé de défendre les policiers de dire
non les hommes et les femmes policiers
dans ce pays ne sont pas racistes ça
vous inspire quoi vous vous dites que la
situation est arrivée à un point
un gars mais vous savez vous devez
employer faire vous utilisez des pertes
qui a fait présume totalement la
situation
c'est à dire qu'on est dans un contexte
où on selon les échos mondiale et le
dialogue il analyse se résume à des
slogans contre sedan en fait foi les
plus loin de tabaski dommage qu'il n'y a
pas
tous les policiers ne sont pas parfaits
et enfin s'il y a malgré tout même une
opposition qu'ils soient issus de la
délinquance ou de l'opposition sociale
sont très forts qu alors s'arc bouter
sur des concepts du style la police n'a
jamais tort est aussi intelligent que de
dire que les délinquants sont tous
blancs bleus enfin ça n'a pas de sens où
vraiment espérer il faut souhaiter que
les gens qui ont des choses
intéressantes à dire et qui ont des
désirs et des analyses porteuse de
solutions prennent la parole soit
entendue le plus fort que ceux qui ne
raisonnent que parent je répète que par
ce slogan tout n'est pas blanc tout
n'est pas noir que ce soit d'un côté
comme de l'autre il va falloir se donner
la peine d'y réfléchir
en tout cas là ce rapport on assiste
démontre malheureusement que toute
politique pénale toute politique
judiciaire en tout politique
je dirais d'implantation de colonies
dans les quartiers est de plus en plus
compliqué parce que ça n'est pas que
dans ce secteur de paris ou dans des
secteurs très ciblée de la région
parisienne qu'il ya des problèmes il y a
des problèmes de ce genre du moins
détention de ce genre par tous au
territoire national il va fort à un
moment donné qu'on fasse qu'on arrête de
faire semblant qu'il n'existe pas de
problème
merci beaucoup aux jean-pierre colombiès
porte parole de l'association policière
huppé ni d'avoir été avec nous et c'est
là